so this is the lineup for today we're
going to be talking about language today
and on wednesday
but i want to start with something that
i gave very short shrift at the end of
lecture last time and i'm going to give
it short shrift again but in a slightly
different way you'll need this for the
reading
which hopefully you've already tried
started as a representational similarity
analysis is
subtle and rich and interesting and it's
taken me years of revisiting it to get
its full force so just keep going at it
and hopefully every time you'll get it a
little better so let me try another
brief version of this
so
representational similarity analysis
is sort of like a generalized case of
multiple voxel pattern analysis that
applies to other kinds of methods and it
characterizes a bigger
conceptual space so to remind you
multiple voxel pattern analysis with
functional mri is this business where
you split your data in half so you have
one set of scans where people are
looking at say dogs in another set where
they're looking at cats and a whole
other separate replication where they're
looking at dogs and cats you look at the
pattern of response across voxels in
each of those four conditions dog one
dog two cat one cat two
and you ask if the pattern is more
similar for the two different splits of
the data in the same condition dog one
dog two and cat one cat two the diagonal
here then in the two cases where they're
different dogs to cats
everybody remember that this should be
like if you're having trouble with this
come see me or the tas that's not good
okay
okay so now that's
mvpa
and you can use that to ask of a given
region of interest in the brain
or the whole brain if that the pattern
of response in that region can
distinguish between class a and class b
that's what it's good for
so
that's worth knowing but it's kind of
impoverished it's binary i mean cats
versus dogs okay it's a dopey example i
choose but whatever you choose is just
going to be two things it only takes you
so far in characterizing what's
represented in that region
you can make it richer if you force it
to generalize so if these two are a
smaller
size and a different viewpoint from
those and it still works then we show
that there's generality train on one
kind of condition test on a slightly
different version of them that tests the
invariance that's richer and more
interesting
but even so
it's it's limited
so representational similarity analysis
is a bigger richer way of characterizing
representations by looking at the
pattern of response across multiple
conditions not just two in their
variations so instead of something like
this we'd have something like this with
a whole bunch of different stimuli or
conditions that we scan people on and
then we look at all the pairwise
combinations how similar is dog to cat
how similar is it to pig or horse or you
know table or chair or whatever right so
then we have all of these pairwise
similarities which gives gives us a
bigger you know a richer idea of what's
going on there okay and so now we don't
have to choose a binary classification
in there we can look at that entire
space we can think of this whole space
as
what is represe as our proxy for what is
represented in that region of the brain
okay
so now that's cool so everybody sort of
get the gist of how this
set of pairwise similarities in a region
of the brain
is a kind of richer
idea of what's going on in that region
and what it cares about right everybody
kind of got that sort of
okay now chunk that matrix
as one thing okay that's a
representation
of
what's represented in this part of the
brain
but now we can take that unit and we can
say we can do the same thing on a
totally different kind of data
okay
so
here's what we just did here's like some
region of the brain
voxels
we can do the same thing in behavior
now we can say okay you rate for me how
similar is a dog to a cat on a scale
from one to ten
i don't know six or something okay
how similar
is a cat to a pig
four i don't know right you can see you
imagine you get some similarity space
you could just get people to rate them
and you could make a whole new matrix
here
okay
now you're characterizing your
conceptual space over those same items
behaviorally by asking people how
similar similar each thing are here
we're comparing similarity of patterns
of responses across voxels here we're
doing it by asking how similar it seems
to people behaviorally everybody get how
that's a similar kind of enterprise
or we could record from neurons in
monkey brains and show them the same
pictures
and just look at the response across say
100 neurons in the monkey brain to a dog
and a cat and a pig and so forth
and then we could ask how similar is a
response across neurons in the monkey
to each pair of stimuli just as we did
that across each pa each
each pair of stimuli across voxels
everybody got that
so in each case we're getting a matrix
like this
now
we can do the totally cool oh sorry
we're not quite yet we can also do that
not just on functional mri voxels in the
whole brain or in one region but we can
make separate matrices these are
obviously all fake data i didn't take
the trouble to make different matrices
for each right
but we could make different matrices for
different regions of interest in the
brain
okay one for each
voxels here what's their pairwise set of
similarities across those stimuli voxels
over here what's their pairwise set of
similarities
okay
now we can correlate these matrices to
each other
okay so we can say for example
we had a bunch of people do ratings and
give us their behavioral similarities
based over these stimuli
and then we looked in some region of the
brain and got the brain's similarity
space and they're represent and their
responses across voxels
how similar are those to each other
okay
so it's like we've moved up a level
each matrix is a set of correlations
between each pair of stimuli but then
once we have that set of correlations we
can take the whole matrix and correlate
it to another matrix
this would be a way of asking in some
region of the brain
how well
does the representation in this chunk of
brain
match people's subjective impression of
that similarity space when you ask them
about it everybody see how that's a way
to ask that question
okay we can also
relate functional mri voxels to
neurophysiology responses across neurons
we can ask
how similar is your
ffa's let's not take the ffa your lo
that likes object shape how similar is
its shape space in your brain measured
with functional mri
to shape space in this part of the
monkey's brain
registered with neurophysiology
that's pretty cosmic right
we're asking if the monkey sees the
world the same way you do in a sense for
this method by using these matrices and
asking how similar they are across
species and methods yeah
you can do whatever you like
okay so you can take
you know you can do garden variety
functional mri like we've been talking
about in here just like the haxby thing
from 2001 that's when it all started
right just get a vector across voxels
for one condition a vector across voxels
for the two condition and correlate them
you can do that in responses across
neurons
okay but you can also do more exotic
things you can train a linear classifier
on a bunch of voxels and say how well
can it decode the response to pig to the
response to dog
and you can put that number in the in
that cell
okay so you can do it different ways any
measure of similarity or very
confusingly there's an increasing trend
to talk about dissimilarity not
similarity by subtracting the r values
from one i find that annoying but it's
all over the literature and who cares
whether it's similarity or dissimilarity
it doesn't really matter they're both
ways of uh collecting a representational
space
yeah
are there any any debates in the demand
that we should be available since this
is like a correlation of coordination oh
a million you're supposed to fisher
transform it and do all that garbage and
we're not discussing that in here i'm
just trying to give you the idea i don't
need to be dismissive i'm skipping over
all of that stuff to just give you the
gist of the idea you know for present
for purposes in this class you could
just eyeball that in that you'd say oh
they're really uh no they're not
identical i guess i did switch it
i did switch a few of them oh okay
anyway whatever
for purposes in this class you could
just eyeball them mathematically and r
value we're leaving out all the details
yeah
okay
and of course we can compare behavior in
a person to physiology in a monkey or
behavior in a monkey to physiology in a
monkey
and here's one thing you need for the
reading i hope it didn't already stump
you it's in a tiny part of one of the
figures
we can make up a hypothesis of what
what's represented here we might say hey
consider this patch of
a brain maybe it represents the animate
inanimate distinction in the ideal case
that would mean
all it knows is animals versus
non-animals okay
and so that would mean this should be
the representational symbolism
similarity space if these are all the
animals they're all exactly the same as
each other all the non-animals are the
same as each other but animal any animal
and any non-animal are different so this
is a hypothesized similarity space of
our guess of what's represented in a
region a model of what we think is
represented in a region and we can we
can correlate that to any of these
matrices to ask whether our hypothesis
of what's in there is right does that
make sense
okay
okay so why is that so all this whole
thing so totally cool
it enables us to compare
representational spaces across regions
of interest in the brain
okay the ffa to the ppa do they have
similar representational spaces
across subject groups
this batch of subjects and that batch of
subjects
without having to align voxels
we're not aligning voxels we've left
loxels behind we're only using these
matrices
okay
we can do it across species across
methods
and across hypothesized models of what
we think is going on
like that
okay
so more generally this probes
representations in a richer way we don't
need to have just 10 or whatever i put
there we could have if we keep subjects
in the scanner long enough for monkeys
in the lab long enough we can get
hundreds of stimuli and really
characterize a rich space
and we're looking at not just two
discriminations but lots
um the key requirement for
representational similarity analysis
to be able to do all this cool stuff
is the axes need to be the same
so the stimuli that you're getting the
similarity of need to be the same in the
person doing behavior the person doing
mri the monkey doing physiology the
model if the axes are not the same then
there's no way to correlate the matrices
make sense
okay we'll keep coming at this again and
again you'll see it in the paper for
tomorrow night and we'll come at it
again
uh in class on wednesday
okay so that was all ketchup
so today we are going to talk about
language
and let's start by reflecting on what an
amazing thing language is
so right now
there's a miraculous thing going on
i'm taking some weird abstract
hard to grasp even for me kind of ideas
someplace in my head god knows where
somewhere in there
and i'm trying to take those ideas
and translate them
into this bunch of noises coming out my
mouth that's already pretty astonishing
like what
what does that idea look like who the
hell knows how do you take an abstract
idea and turn it into a string of sounds
that's wild nobody really knows pretty
much a damn thing about how that works
fascinating mystery
right but then
that bunch of noises is going through
the air
and producing let's hope
pretty similar ideas in your head
wow
okay we do this all day every day big
deal but it is it's astonishing it's
just astonishing that that works at all
okay
so that's the essence of language that's
why it's so cool
um and let's think about
um
how we're going to think about this so
the first thing to note is
language is universally human
all neurologically intact humans have
language
there are about 7 000 languages in the
world sadly this number's shrinking all
the time
they are all richly expressive including
sign languages there are no kind of
impoverished languages that don't
capture the full richness of
expressible human experience they're all
equally rich
language is uniquely human
yes chimps and parrots can accomplish
all kinds of cool things especially if
you train them extensively
but what they have is not anything
really like language
and to give you a vivid sense of this
let's look at chaser the border collie
and what i want you to think about as
you look at this little video of chaser
the border collie is what is the
difference between your language
abilities and chasers chaser's pretty
damned impressive
but you are more impressive so watch it
and enjoy and think about how it's
different from what you do
of us burst with pride if our dogs can
respond to two or three commands but
what if we haven't begun to understand
the possibilities of what the animal
mind can really do
our friend astrophysicist neil degrasse
tyson is host of nova science now and he
brings us big news from the frontier
welcome
chaser
beloved six-year-old border collie of
psychology professor john pilly good
girl she was born to live in the
scottish mountains chase
and heard she go go john has taught
chaser to tend an extremely large if
unconventional herd
of a thousand toys and she knows the
name of every single one of these i hope
i find this hard to believe so i test
chaser's memory with a random sampling
chaser find inky
well she got one right
find
seal
whoa
and that one too
in fact she got all nine right but what
about a new toy she's never seen or
heard the name of chaser's never seen
darwin hasn't even ever heard the name
darman
so we're going to see if she picks out
darwin by inference find
darwin
i have to ask her again
okay chaser
chaser chaser
find
darwin
[Music]
she did it
chaser's never seen that doll before yet
she settled on the one toy she didn't
know
by deduction
it's similar to the way children learn
language but how does chaser's ability
compare with other species
besides us chimps and bonobos are the
animal kingdom's top linguists capable
of learning sign language but very
slowly
they can solve some sophisticated
problems but they don't always pay close
attention to humans is he come here i
see my dog my dog wants me to be around
whereas a bunch of people they don't
need me they're basically like hey you
got any food can i get any food off of
you they're not interested in making me
happy since dogs do like to please
that humans need to find a way to tap
the potential in all of our houses okay
put in the tub
and dogs like chaser are just waiting
for us to discover all that they can do
smart dog
[Music]
and neil degrasse tyson is here with the
astonishing chaser here
tell me what you learned about
animal behavior and child behavior who
would have thought that the animals are
capable of this much display of
intellect i think we like thinking of
humans as some top of some ladder and
don't even imagine that other animals
could even approximate what we do
all right i think we all want to see
what the demo can we do a demo of this
sure
goose
okay can i do this one you can do this
one chaser chaser
find abc
abc you did it
we thank you and we want everyone to
know that it's a truly remarkable nova
tonight four meals reporting tonight on
nova science now on pbs and to you and
your broken dogs at home good night
okay
she's a very good girl
and she knows a lot of nouns
right
a thousand nouns apparently
um but what can't you do that you guys
can do
is this language
yeah
it's word identification it's not
language you can actions how vibrating
to be able to use verbs
together
okay
okay that's good verbs and nouns
together
what else
yeah there's some fortification of
things if there were like a bigger abc
and a smaller bbc type of thing that
distinction would have been possible
alex the parent can do that one i don't
have a video of alex and i don't want to
get too hung up on this but some animals
can do that kind of stuff
what else
yeah yeah it's probably closer to like
sound identification like how i can
identify like the sound of a train or
the sound of a car
so just some rudimentary thing like
visual form and sound
how about when she found darwin
sorry it wasn't that case just like like
he said deduction it was just like it
wasn't any other ones that's right
that's right but that's pretty
impressive isn't it
turns out kids use that rule too in
learning language it's a whole
set of studies of how kids use rules to
try to figure out what people are
referring to when they learn novel words
and that's one of the things that kids
use
is if there's a thing here that i don't
know when somebody's saying a sound here
i don't know that thing is probably goes
with the sound yeah yeah i would say
like i took 1985 last semester we talked
about like an exact experiment where
kids were able to like
learn the words of toys that were like
not like english words that were like
dax and stuff but then when they were
given like a new object they would be
able to identify it as a different
exactly mutual it's called mutual
exclusivity and that's exactly what what
chaser's showing here
okay so pretty impressive but not fully
language right more like memorizing a
bunch of nouns plus mutual exclusivity
plus some other stuff maybe
um she certainly can't understand who
did what to who and why
right that's just this is not even in
the ballpark this is kind of the essence
of what we talk to each other about
is this kind of stuff
all kinds of complicated relationships
between different concepts
that we
communicate in language
so animals in not just taught english
but animals in their natural
environments communicate in rich and
detailed ways with each other but
usually in each case about a very
restricted domain
you know what what kind of danger is
around what kind of food sources around
those basic kinds of narrow things that
are of survival value those are the
things that animal communication systems
usually deal with and in contrast human
languages are
open-ended
and compositional right compositional
means that we combine words to say new
things
things no human being has ever said
before
okay so that you don't see in animals
okay
okay so what is language cognitively
that is what do you have to know to know
a language
okay a bunch of basic things
one is phonology the sounds of language
we've talked about this a bit in the
case of speech perception just hearing
the difference between a ba and a pa
or seeing the equivalent gesture
american sign language is a fully
expressive natural language and there
the phonemes are different pieces of
hand movements rather than sounds but
function as phonemes all the same
okay we talked about specif a region of
the brain that responds very
specifically to speech sounds in humans
okay moving up into the language system
that's just the input system
we have and by the way we also talked
about the visual word form area a very
recent addition to the input system in
language but that's only a few thousand
years old it's really phenology that's
the native form of language that's been
around for
uh tens if not hundreds of thousands of
years in human evolution
so semantics we need to know what words
mean that's lexical semantics but we
also need to know how meaning arises
when words go together
okay
and related to how words go together we
need to know about the syntax of a
language that is the structure or
grammar of a language all right
and so each language has a set of rules
about how you string words together in
that language and usually central to
that not the only thing but a central
part of that is word order
and that whole set of rules for how you
string together words following word
order rules determines the meaning of
the string of words for example
shark bites man is different than men by
shark okay and that just comes out of
the syntax that we know that in english
in this kind of construction the first
word is going to be
the agent the one who's doing the thing
and the third word is going to be the
patient the one who's receiving the
doing okay and that's just built into
your language system that you know that
implicitly
okay
there's also the pragmatics of language
that is how we understand what somebody
actually means when they say something
to us
which isn't always just a function of
the actual string of words coming out
their mouth okay so if somebody says it
will be awesome if you pass the salt
it's not all that awesome to have the
salt it really means please pass the
salt right
the pragmatics of the situation tells
you the actual intent
yeah
okay and so to do pragmatics involves
thinking about the other person's intent
what are they thinking what do they want
what's going on in their head and using
all that background knowledge to
constrain
what do they mean by this particular
utterance
okay so that's just a survey of the main
pieces
of what we mean by language but for the
next two lectures we're going to focus
on the core which is syntax and
semantics uh this stuff in here and i
will sloppily use the word language to
refer to this stuff not all the other
stuff
and and we'll focus really on the
sentence understanding
okay so what do we want to know about
sentence understanding
well the first thing we want to know is
is it even a thing
right is is language a thing separate
from the rest of thought okay
second thing we want to know is if it is
at least something of a kind of a thing
does language itself have component
structure within it are there different
parts of the language system that maybe
do different things
and if so what is represented and
computed in each of those parts
and third how do we represent meaning in
the brain
okay so these are the things we'll
address over the next two lectures and
let's start with this question that will
probably take up the bulk of this
lecture
is language distinct from the rest of
thought
okay
another way of putting this a more
familiar way is to ask what is the
relationship between language and
thought or even more pointedly could you
think without language
you probably every one of you has
wondered about that at some point so
take like two or three minutes talk to
your neighbors about this see if you can
figure out whether you can think without
language and then let's pull your
insights
talk
okay if you guys all nailed it i'm sure
you solved the whole thing right
people have been talking about this for
you know probably millennia so
um what do you guys think
what were some of your reflections on
this question
come on you guys yes quietly uh we okay
i said that like i think that they could
think of that language because of
like we talked previously about how uh
registration like babies are capable
like very complex topic
um
he was like arguing that
the oil research like there's also this
thing that maybe it's like kind of like
their own language that we don't
understand but i don't think
not really if you take three-month-old
babies not really so perfect absolutely
you already know you can hear this okay
babies can think right you take 985
you'll learn more they can really think
about all kinds of stuff it's really
amazing how much they understand
um and at you know three to six months
there's like little or no language so
there's a beautiful case of thinking
without language yeah david on the other
side right
like if you don't give a name to
something if you don't give a word to
something then it's hard to really know
it like maybe there are uh 20 different
types of in the color green
and if you don't decide to call one of
an olive or another one
khaki screening or something like that
then you can't see the difference
yeah well i don't know if you'd ever
think of the difference you okay let's
think about this
do you think you could see the
difference suppose i held up you know
all of an olive patch and a khaki patch
to you and for whatever reason you had
been raised with deprivation of the
words olive and khaki but somehow it's
not about just the perception question
it's about remembering yeah bingo bingo
so that's roughly what the literature
shows anya helped me out here i forgot
to look this up the literature still
show that perceptually you can
discriminate them just fine it doesn't
make a damn bit of difference if you
have words for it but if you have to
remember it sorry
faster faster okay but accuracy of d
prime i don't think is different
maybe a little bit
okay oops caught i meant to look this up
i knew this was going to come up okay
write me an email to look this up and
help me find the relevant stuff anyway
it doesn't make a huge difference
perceptually but it does if you have to
remember it for later
yeah i was actually going to say because
i'm actually reproducing the experiment
that found that the difference there was
a difference in cognitive
in wait in perception or memory um so
they found that
i believe it was um
because they've been a long history with
this they find one thing and that's
partly why it was like a difference in
reaction time interesting enough they
found that if they introduced
interference in their like linguistic
system then that difference went away so
that's evidence that the language is
causing the difference
and that's in a perceptual
discrimination okay first scholars yeah
yeah well
behavioral well yeah effects often are
yeah as well i remember one of the first
neuroscience talks that went to my
college was a
woman who had been obviously happy with
that was terribly stroke and she was
separated from people asia year after
week and speaking
and put all the language and would like
to appear like here
i remember the question that i asked is
you know
you have this really terrible thing
right you know did you like what did
your inner voice sound like and she said
well i didn't know you have one and
we've walked into a thing
and then she said well i must have
thought into images and feelings and the
interesting thing that you know i
experienced when i was reading my talk
was that you know the more english i
learned the more my thoughts comes with
grammar so i still you know could have
these thoughts but they were formulated
in this
way than they were when i had
the structured language
okay that's great so we're going to
learn more about all of that
absolutely
okay very good
um so cool question not obvious let's
see what the data say
so first of all you guys uh talked about
uh babies and how they can think but
animals can think too maybe not fully as
richly as we can but they can think in
all kinds of subtle rich ways and
animals don't have language and so
that's another case animals and infants
and i'm mentioning numerosity because
these are things we happen to have
mentioned in here remember the
approximate number system animals are
great at that very young infants are
great at that when they don't have
language at all
also by the way people whose language do
not have any number words whatsoever
can do approximate numerosity
so here's a cool study
from ted gibson's lab a few years ago
they went down into remote parts of the
amazon to study this group of people the
para ha
here they are in their canoe
they are a hunter-gatherer tribe of just
a few hundred
their language is as far as linguists
can tell unrelated to anyone else and it
has no number words so there's a whole
there's a whole dispute about that but
the current view is there really no
number words at all not even for zero or
one
okay so how do they do at approximate
magnitude
well let's see
so here is the testing session down in
the amazon
and this is the experimenter lining up
a bunch of i think they're batteries and
this guy's asked to match the number of
balloons to the number of batteries and
he has to do it aligned this way so he
can't just put them one next to the
other if you let him he'll put them one
next to the other
but this is designed to
test it better and he puts down four
balloons
bingo very good
okay
what no number of words in his language
okay
what about
um
this case
i hate people
oh the plot is thickening
with a lot of thread
he laughs he thinks that's pretty funny
but watch
this
valiant goes ahead
really well
okay
so he i think he gave nine for ten or
something like that anyway um
if uh if if i had any of you guys do
this task and i prevented you from
counting by having you do verbal
shadowing or something else to tie up
your language system you would do
exactly the same as this guy does okay
so the approximate number system doesn't
require language doesn't require number
words in your language to get the
concept and it doesn't require use of
language to do the task
sorry he actually saw a man put all of
him he saw yeah yeah just like you
should
yeah just just that i mean that's the
actual experiment being conducted right
there okay
okay
okay
so we've just argued that at least the
approximate number system
is present in animals who don't have a
number of words infants who don't and
people who don't have adults who don't
have number words
what about other aspects of thought
and what can we learn from studying
brain disorders as isabelle mentioned a
moment ago very rich source
okay so here's the question we're
considering we're taking language and
thought or cognition and we're asking
whether they're totally separate in the
mind and brain
or whether they're
totally the same thing or whether
there's some relationship but they're
somewhat different okay so that's a
question
what do we learn from brain disorders
well let's start for with developmental
disorders and there are unfortunately a
large number of these
for example there are language savants
people with down syndrome
williams syndrome turner syndrome these
are all developmental disorders in which
people have
very low iqs but notably in each of
these cases very good language
perhaps the most striking is williams
syndrome these kids are remarkable they
have very low iqs they can't
do the most basic spatial reasoning
tasks they can't cross the street safely
they can't you know they they can't live
independently at all and yet they're
highly social and their language is
almost indistinguishable from
any of yours
okay not quite if you test them subtly
you can find some differences but it is
rich and complex and it's it's bizarre
because you'd think if your thoughts are
so impoverished because your iq is low
how could you have rich language but
that's the weird thing about william
syndrome their language is extremely
rich and in fact poetic and quite
beautiful and expressive
so that's really surprising
and suggests that you can have
quite severely impaired cognition and
very good language so that's the first
crack that these things are more
separate than you'd guess actually i
find this one more surprising than all
the others
but
in cases of brain damage
which was
the first mental function localized in
the brain
so this is historically important way
back in 1861 paul broca
stood up in front of the anthropology
society of paris and he announced that
the left frontal lobe was the seat of
speech okay and this is on the basis of
his patient tan
who had a big nasty lesion right there
in what became known as broca's area
um tan was his name because after that
lesion that was all he could say
okay
so broca this is back when the
mainstream view was very much against
localization of function in the brain
there were people like franz josef gaul
who were going around saying that
different parts of the brain did very
different things but goal was kind of a
nut and he was not taken seriously by
the academic elite whereas broca was a
fancy member of the
french you know academic societies and a
muckety muck and when he announced that
the left frontal lobe is the seat of
speech everybody had to pay attention so
it was big stuff
importantly broken noted that tan wasn't
globally impaired at thinking
that tan could do all kinds of things
even though he could not speak so he was
already onto this critical idea way back
in 1861 and he's just the most famous uh
in that in that group there were a bunch
of people before him in the decades
before who were reporting similar kinds
of dissociations
okay so what would it be like to have
intact thought
despite impaired language okay so
isabelle mentioned asking somebody who
had a stroke
here's a
okay right so here's another case this
is a case of this guy here tom lubbock
who died a few years ago
from a brain tumor in his temporal lobe
that destroyed most of his language
but it destroyed it gradually and this
guy was a writer he was an art critic a
critic for a major
english paper
and as he started to lose language he
wrote about it and he wrote about it
very beautifully
and he said
my language to describe things in the
world is very small
limited
my thoughts when i look at the world are
vast limitless and normal
same as they ever were
my experience of the world is not made
less by lack of language but is
essentially unchanged
so that's a very powerful and surprising
piece of writing
it's a little bit mysterious because
here's this guy writing beautifully and
telling us his language is impaired so
his idea of language impairment may not
be mine i wish i could write that well
nonetheless he's clearly reflecting on
you know what is a very big loss of his
previous language ability and i'm sure
it was very painstaking to write these
sentences
and he's still telling us that even
though he's lost a lot of language it
has not changed his experience
okay so that's just one
subjective impression so that argues
against this extreme view that they're
the same thing right
um but it leaves a lot of slop yes
because he had a key point of
speaking and learning
about the award before yes a very
important point absolutely so this is a
case of somebody who had a lesion
in midlife 40 50 something like that he
had a whole lifetime of using language
to learn and bootstrap all of cognition
so absolutely we have to separate two
different questions do you need language
to become a normal intelligent
functional human being
throughout you know do you need it
throughout development or once you've
developed
do you still need it to think and those
are two very different questions and in
fact absolutely you need language to
develop
if you reflect for a moment on all the
things you know
okay take a quick mental inventory
survey all the things you know it's a
lot of things right
almost all of those you learn because
somebody told you
okay
most of what we know we learn from
language maybe you read about it right
but that's somebody telling you in a
different way
right
okay so language is crucial for
development of cognition and for
learning absolutely
but now we're asking a different
question of whether you need it whether
it's the same thing in adulthood
okay
so the
this guy is a little bit complicated
because he obviously still has a lot of
language left let's consider
cases of people who have essentially no
language due to brain damage so this is
known as global aphasia
and rosemary varley in england has been
studying a group of three people i think
she's got a few more but here are her
three three main ones who have global
ephesians she's been studying them for a
few years
and um sorry it doesn't show here at all
sorry about this lousy projector shows
on my screen they're big nasty lesions
taking up a lot of the left hemisphere
and basically knocking out you know
essentially all the language regions
in these three individuals and here's
their performance on a bunch of
different language tasks
they have to look at a picture and name
it
they have to understand reversible
sentences that's like uh boy kiss girl
versus girl kiss boy they need to know
who did the kissing and who got kissed
right
um and a whole bunch of questions like
that and they are at chance at every one
of these
okay so these are people not just people
who can't speak
they're people who can't speak or
understand language pretty much at all
okay so it's as close as we can get to a
case of a person who has no language
ability
okay
so can these people think
so
rosemary varley has done
paper after paper in which she finds
clever ways to communicate tasks to
these people to find out what kind of
thinking they're capable of
here's one
you have to order this series of
pictures
okay so look at it for a second and you
can figure out that it goes uh
you know basically from right to left
okay
um so can people with global aphasia do
this task
yes they're perfect at it no problem
whatsoever
okay
now you might dispute is that cause and
effect is it knowledge of sequences are
they different i don't know but anyway
it's pretty rich
task here okay here's another task
look at these pictures and tell which of
them are things you know and which of
them are things you have never seen
before
that i drew
okay
takes a moment but you can figure it out
okay top three things are real things
and those three things are things i drew
okay
so we could ask does a person with
global aphasia know the difference
basically do you have to
be able to name things to know the
difference of what's a real thing and
what's not
here's another task
which of these is the plausible event
that's more complicated because here we
need to know here we just need to know
is that a real thing that i know here we
need to know who's doing what to who and
does it make sense
so it taps world knowledge figuring out
who's doing what to whom which many
people think is at the core of language
so how do people global global aphasia
do
perfectly at both of these things well
not perfectly but the same as control
subjects yeah
um i'm just confused like how do you get
the question like across what they need
to do i don't know exactly but you do
something like
for example you ever play charades like
that
so like
it's not exactly
like could someone argue that like
there's like actions that you're doing
or some kind of form of like
language their communication they're not
language
okay so when we say language we really
mean language not necessarily noises
coming out the mouth because american
sign language counts
um and we didn't have time to put that
in this lecture which is a damn shame
because it really does count in every
way and is very interesting and uses
similar neural structures and all that
stuff
um but language is different than
communication there's all kinds of ways
of communicating right
yeah how old are these patients again
uh i don't know exactly but they're
probably it's almost always strokes
they're probably 40 to 60. it's
developed i mean it's it's not really
it's not a sort of infant no no no these
are all people who had brain damage
in midlife or later in life
yeah okay so that's pretty impressive
okay
um
so basically
these people with global aphasia are
able to do every single task that
rosemary varley has tested them on
so i just showed you causality nonverbal
meaning
here's a cool one remember reorientation
you should
may well be on the final exam to remind
you
i did a whole like most of a lecture on
this thing about reorientation remember
rats and infants
if you put them hide food there and put
them in this box they later go 50 50 to
the two corners
even though that wall should
disambiguate which is the exactly
correct corner
they should always go here they have the
knowledge that it's there but they go 50
50.
okay and remember i said that liz spelke
has this interesting argument that the
key thing you need to be able to solve
that task is language
right because in fact if you test adults
and you tie up their language system
they behave like infants and rats
but if you don't tie up their language
system they can do the task which is
pretty suggestive that language is the
crux of the matter
however the global aphasics do this test
just fine
okay
so now we have to go to min young's
hypothesis which is that
maybe the role of language in
reorientation is learning about that
whole spatial system
during childhood which the global
aphasics could do not maintaining the
ability once you've gained it
okay
all right they can do i won't give you
all the data on this but they can do
arithmetic tasks
logic tasks algebra tasks they
appreciate music
they can think about what other people
are thinking
okay
so everything that all the kind of high
level abstract
quintessentially human abilities that we
are impressed with ourselves for being
able to do these people can do without
language so language and thought are not
the same thing
okay
you can still think in lots of different
ways even after you use language
on the other hand
as what has already been brought up
global of physics had language during
development okay so saying that you
don't need it as an adult is not the
same as saying you don't need it during
development you absolutely do need it
during development
okay because it's the key way we learn
about the world
and for example there are studies
from rebecca sax's lab showing that deaf
kids who learn language later
for example if they're born not to deaf
parents but to hearing parents who don't
cotton on to the fact that it's
important for them to learn asl early
and hence they don't get language until
later
those kids are not as good at
understanding what other people are
thinking something that we usually learn
about through language
okay
okay
further
even though i'm making a big deal about
how you can think without language i'm
not saying that
languages are relevant to thinking okay
every time i write a grant proposal i
think oh god i have all these ideas in
my head and i have to waste weeks and
weeks and weeks
putting them all down on paper to try to
get money to fund my habit
and then i get into like sentence three
and i suddenly realize oh oh no i
haven't been thinking about this clearly
at all right so this is my very informal
introspection on the role of language in
my own thinking like even when i think
there's a clear thought the same thing
happens when i go to prepare a lecture
it's like oh yeah i know the stuff that
i've put together some slides i'm like
slide two
no i don't really know this stuff
right
um so there is some role uh for language
and thinking
and i'll give you one uh one example
here um
one one of the many things that language
can do is to uh make information more
salient
okay
so
right now close your eyes everyone close
your eyes i mean it i can see if they're
open
okay
while keeping your eyes closed
point south
okay you may not exactly know where
south is but make a good guess
okay
point use your whole arm so everyone can
see when they open their eyes
okay okay keep pointing but now you can
open your eyes and you can look around
and see where everyone else is pointing
you guys are not bad
not bad not bad but we got some over
here a little turned around here
it's roughly over there
okay
um so yeah
hang on wait a second a little bit yes
right
um
well hang on no i don't know yeah right
it's over there
okay
um okay
so you know your vector average was
closer to the true thing than a random
vector but not so hot
if your language forced you to keep
track of this you'd be better at it
and we know that from the case of the
palm para these guys here who live in
australia aboriginal people
and
they
spend a lot of time going around in the
remote outback of australia where they
need to know where they are
and where who is going where and when is
really of the essence in their lives and
in their social interactions
so when they run into each other they
don't say hi how are you
instead they say which way are you going
and a typical answer might be north
northwest in the middle distance how
about you
okay
um
they don't talk about things being left
or right or behind them
reference frames that have to do with
the person's own body which are frankly
really stupid reference frames because i
can say this thing is to the left
and then i turn and now it's not to the
left anymore like how stupid is that
right
these guys have a much better system
they would rather say oh you have a bug
on your southeast leg
right
okay
so these guys people who speak this
language they have to be aware of
absolute compass directions all the time
just to speak
okay and so they're oriented all the
time
unlike us and in that sense their
language makes salient
certain kinds of information it's not
that you know we can't think about
direction it's just that most of the
time we're not aware because our
language doesn't force us to think about
it
yeah
okay
so interim summary
um
we've been asking this question of
whether
thought is separate from and possible
without language okay before you guys
take off you wrote it on the board this
board right here awesome okay
uh you guys need to tell me when there's
time to take the quiz so you're gonna
have seven minutes because there's seven
questions and so at um
uh 12
18.
um let me know and i will turn the board
around okay 12 17 because it'll take me
a minute to turn around all right thank
you take notes tell me about that talk
okay
so here's a question we've been engaging
in is thoughts separate from and
possible without language
and the the literature from a neuropsych
patient says yes absolutely they're
totally separate
global of physics have many forms of
thought without language
so given that what would you predict
from functional mri
so if i told you which is true that
these are the brain regions that are
active during language tasks for example
when you understand the meaning of a
sentence
what would you predict should they be
activated
only by language not by non-linguistic
tasks what do you think take a moment to
think about it
these are the regions that are engaged
when you understand the meaning of a
sentence would you expect them to be
engaged based on what i've just told you
when you do mental arithmetic
when you think about spatial
orientations
when you appreciate music
no
right if they're separate they're
separate they should go on in different
brain regions everybody have that
intuition
no you don't have that intuition
i mean
i mean you you think about things in
terms of words
even as a mental crutch even if you
didn't have to okay fair enough fair
enough so it doesn't nail this case it
could well be
that you have separate systems for all
those other things but you still lean on
the system not necessarily but you use
it sometimes in fact there's evidence
for that that we won't get to today but
um okay but the initial thought is you
don't need to activate it right okay
well here's the surprise
up until recently
pretty much the whole brain imaging
literature says that language overlaps
with all of these things in the brain
that the activations overlap in the
brain they're all the same thing
okay that's been the received story
for
20 years or so of brain imaging
and that just does not fit with the
patient literature
so we have a conundrum
here just a few examples
um stand ahead
says arithmetic recruits networks
involved in word association processes
people who study music say regions such
as broca's area and wernicke's area
which have been considered specific to
language are also activated by certain
aspects of music thus the idea of
language specificity has been called
into question and on and on there's a
million of these i just put a few of
them up there
okay so
what's going on how are we going to
resolve this contradiction on the one
hand the patient literature suggests
that language is separate from the rest
of thought and on the other hand most of
the neuroimaging literature says that if
you look at those language regions you
find them activated in all these other
kinds of things
one hypothesis is david's that they're
activated but not essentially so
but there's another hypothesis
and that is that there's a
methodological flaw with most of the
prior research
okay
what is that methodological flaw
it's an inappropriate use of something
called a group analysis i've alluded to
this a few times briefly but let me do
it for real now okay let me first say
it's not that a group analysis with
functional mri is an evil thing that
should never be done
they have uses but particularly for the
question of asking whether
common regions of the brain are engaged
in two different tasks it is not a good
method for the following reason so first
let's say what is a group analysis
with functional mri it just means and
again i'm going to be very sketchy with
this because this is not a actual
hands-on methods class i'm just trying
to get you to understand the gist of the
methods
you take a bunch of scanned brains and
you align them in a common space as best
you can
okay you can't do it perfectly because
brains are anatomically different from
one person to the next okay
but you do your best to align them as
best you can
then you do an analysis across those
aligned brains and you ask what is
consistent across this group of subjects
that's a very useful question to ask if
we want to know overall what are the
brain regions that are consistently
activated when you understand language
across this whole group of subjects
that's a good use of a group analysis
you'll find that picture i just showed
you before with stuff going down the
left temporal lobe a bunch of left
frontal lobe stuff and that will be a
very blurry picture of the regions that
are most consistent across subjects yes
charter you line them anatomically as a
new map like sell side to each other or
if you
like blinded functions
okay so therein lies a universe of
options what i'm talking about now as a
group analysis is aligning them
anatomically
and that's where the problem comes in
and where we're going to go from that is
you need to align them functionally
okay if you just align them anatomically
then the following can happen
so you do a standard group analysis and
you say for example let's do a language
task an arithmetic task and a music task
and let's suppose you find this
basically broca's area vicinity is
activated in an overlapping fashion in
all three
okay each of those is based on an
analysis of 12 or 20 subjects aligned as
best we can
okay so that's basically what the
literature shows is lots of stuff like
that
but here's the problem
you can get that result in a group
analysis
even if the actual data
looks like this in each individual
subject
no overlap at all in any subject
but those regions are in slightly
different locations and so if you
average across this you get that
everybody see the problem
so it's not that it's a bad idea to do a
group analysis it's a nice initial
blurry picture of the approximate
consistent locations in the brain for a
given task
the problem is when you say oh there's
overlap therefore the same thing
because you can get this result even if
there's no overlap in any subject at all
okay so the whole literature did this
for 20 years and made all this talk
about how language is on top of
everything else in the brain
and for a long time i was sitting by the
sidelines going oh my god
and then eventually um and federico came
along and she knew about language and i
said let's figure out maybe they're
right maybe that's true
or maybe it's like this let's find out
okay so how do we do that
um what you do is exactly what char dual
mentioned a moment ago you align them
not anatomically but functionally that's
a whole reason to use functional reasons
of interest we've encountered this
before when i was carrying on about why
we do functional localizers with the
fusiform face area this is the same deal
it's just that that insight
started in the back of the head and
hasn't reached the front of the head yet
or it's about here so some people get it
here and the farther forward you go the
less people realize this is an issue
which is really ridiculous because it
gets more and more important as you go
this way some stuff is actually aligned
in the back and nothing is aligned in
the front anyway so what do you do you
do just what we did with the ffa in all
the other regions
one in each subject individually you
identify those language regions okay you
run some localizer it's like okay i got
this and that and that and then once you
identify them you can ask okay does that
region and that subject show activation
for arithmetic no that's next door right
etcetera
everybody got this this is really
important
i guess just because i'm obsessed with
it maybe maybe it's not i honestly don't
know if it's globally important or if
it's just my personal obsession but
you need to know it for this course
we'll leave it at that okay
um so this is standard and people who
study vision and it's less standard in
people who work in other domains but
they're they're slowly cottoning on
okay so how do we identify language
regions in each subject individually
there are lots of possible ways to do
this
but here's the
here's the way i'm going to show you
that's been used a bunch by federenko
and others
so
we start by saying okay let's find
candidate brain regions that respond to
language okay
which i told you by language i mean
sentence understanding for present
purposes
so if we want to look at sentence
understanding we've got to start with
sentence understanding so if you look at
the screen you'll see some of the
stimuli we use
okay so subject is lying in the scanner
and they see that okay and then we can
either give them a task or not and we'll
talk about that in a second
what are we going to compare it to
well there are lots and lots of
different things we could compare it to
the control for different things
but we started off with
this if you read this here
okay so the idea is it's visually
similar you can hear the sounds in your
head you can pronounce those things to
yourself but there's really no syntax
and no meaning
okay
not perfect but the first pass
okay
okay
so when you do that you get activations
that look like this here are four
different subjects and you can see
they're very systematic things see these
three blobs
in each subject and a bunch of stuff in
the temporal lobe like that in each
subject they're quite systematic but
absolutely not identical
okay
all right
so yes it's just what i did okay so now
what do you do next well we just made
this up sentences versus non-word
strings who says that's a good thing to
do
okay so the next thing you do is you
gotta validate your localizer task to
make sure it isn't just like trivial in
some sense so the first question is is
it reliable
okay
so here's session one three different
subjects activations
we'll just scan them again there's a lot
of talk about fancy statistics blah blah
blah just scan them again
okay wow look how similar these two
little hot spots this elongated one i
mean it's remarkable
extremely reliable within a subject
and yet somewhat different across
subjects okay so check one reliable
more interestingly does it generalize
across task and presentation modality
okay so before we just had people
reading sentences and i keep saying
reading is not the native form of
language
so let's replicate that reading and and
now we're adding a memory task so at the
end of each string a little probe comes
up and you have to say was this word or
non-word in the previous
thing
sequence
and let's compare that to just listening
to the sentences
wow look how similar
so that tells us that we're not studying
reading or speech we're studying
language after those things converge
those regions don't care if you saw a
word or heard the word they just care if
you're representing the meaning of a
sentence everybody with me why that's
important
okay
all right check check
okay does it generalize across languages
suppose you're bilingual and speak two
different languages
okay here's two subjects who speak both
english and spanish wow look how similar
okay
so it's really language in general not
english or spanish or a particular
language
okay does it generalize across materials
okay so we could have reading sentences
versus non-words that we've been talking
about here with two different runs in
one subject
or we're gonna have subjects listen
listening to speech versus degraded
speech like this here's the speech case
during my days of house arrest
it felt as though i were no longer part
of the real world
okay versus this
[Music]
okay so very degraded you can't
understand what's being said but it has
similar prosity and some similar
structure and the point is you get very
similar activations with those very
different kinds of contrasts
okay
so now we have really validated this
thing it checks out in all the ways it
should it doesn't care about modality it
does care about meaning
and it does and it's highly reliable so
now we can put it to use now we can ask
what does each of those regions do
all right
so to do that in each participant then
we find those regions with this
localizer okay now let me just step back
a second there's nothing magic about
this localizer per se when you want to
study something
you use common sense you try something
you validate it it may turn out later
that oh the thing that we thought we
were identifying language with this
localizer it's got this other stuff and
then maybe you refine your localizer and
do something different so it's not that
this is the only possible way it was
just a sensible approach yeah
okay
so you use this to find those regions
here they are in these four subjects
and now
um you can say let's find you know so
that you have to figure out some way to
say that thing corresponds to that to
that to that and there's a whole bunch
of math that was invented to do that but
you know you can basically see it
with your eyeballs that those guys
roughly correspond
and those guys roughly correspond
the math is just a way to do that
and then once you've found that region
you can measure its response in a whole
bunch of new conditions and ask what it
does
okay
and in particular
oh so yeah so this is different from a
group analysis
where you don't identify those regions
you just
choose regions anatomically
okay so if we just align them and said
okay that's a region
well we don't have much of the language
stuff there not much there a lot there
not much there okay that's not great
then we take another one and we define
this okay this is a problem no language
stuff here lots of language stuff there
none lots not good
okay everybody see how that's a problem
okay
i guess i'm flogging this we can move on
now
but the main problems with the group
analyses are you might fail to detect
neural activity that's actually there
because it doesn't align well enough
across subjects and so it doesn't reach
threshold it's not consistent
but for present purposes the more
relevant problem is
you might
fail to distinguish between two
different functions because they
variably coexist within that region or
not
okay
so we're not doing that for present
purposes
instead we're going to now go back to
the conundrum
of why do the patient studies suggest
that language is distinct from the rest
of thought but the past functional mri
studies suggest that language overlaps
with other functions in the brain
and we're going to consider the
hypothesis
that if you study individual brains and
localize those regions individually in
each subject
then the story might be different
okay
and it is
so here's the task that federenko and i
did a few years ago we came up with
seven different tasks i won't bore you
with all the details it doesn't really
matter
we just had lots of stuff arithmetic
spatial working memory various cognitive
control tasks working memory tests all
kinds of stuff
focusing on things that music focusing
on stuff that other people had said
overlaps with language in the brain
okay
and so first thing is you got to make
sure those other tasks actually produce
activations because it's easy to make up
a task and have it not do much and then
that's not very interesting
so yes each one of those tasks produce
lots of activation look at all that red
stuff looks like a bunch of pizzas right
okay
so they produce good activations now the
question is do those activations overlap
with the language regions
okay
so let's consider two of them this is
basically wernicke's area and broca's
area two well-known language regions
identified individually in each subject
and now averaging the response over all
the conditions here's a response when
subjects read sentences and non-word
strings
sentences and non-word strings okay
that's how we define those regions but
this is in data that wasn't actually
used to define those regions we held out
some data just to cross-validate it okay
now the question is how do those regions
respond to all of these other things
they don't
pretty much at all
okay
so notice what's happened here the prior
literature shows massive overlap between
language and all these other things
in our data when you identify those
language regions in each subject
individually
and measure the magnitude of response in
those other things they don't respond
so this shows stunning specificity of
the language regions consistent with the
picture that comes from the patient
literature from studies of brain damage
language really is separate in the brain
from all of these things
okay everybody get that picture and the
reason the literature had it wrong is
they were mushing brains together and
blurring the hell out of their data and
drawing wrong conclusions
okay i'm speeding up because i don't
want to run out of time okay
so we started with these questions here
is language distinct for the rest of
thought i'm saying yes language may be
necessary to learn to think and it is
indeed
but the evidence from the
neurological patients is pretty powerful
global physics with pretty much no
language can think in myriad
sophisticated ways and when you do your
functional mri studies right you find
that the language regions in the brain
in fact do not
are not active during non-linguistic
thinking
make sense
questions wow i finished on time
you